all right so Tandberg telecom also known
as just Tandberg the video conferencing
company was a very successful
organization started from scratch around
1990 and then during the next two
decades it was effectively competing and
systematically outperforming all other
market players in the video conferencing
industry by 2010 Tandberg was a
billion-dollar business with a 50%
market share 1,700 employees worldwide
in April 2010 Tandberg was acquired by
the American tech behemoth Cisco Systems
for 19 billion Norwegian kroner that's
approximate that was approximately 3.3
billion US dollars the dollar is
changing these days well actually maybe
the chrome lot is changing anyway so
Tandberg 1990 to 2010 arresting piece
was the legendary success that deserves
to be lifted up priced and studied
Tandberg was characterized by a unique
organizational culture a fantastic sales
team very competent and charismatic
leadership but first of all it had an
engineering team that was able to churn
out spectacular and successful products
for two decades
my name is Alba meadow and I'm here to
give some insight into the Tandberg way
of engineering
first of all the story that I'm going to
tell has nothing to do with Hamburg
display Tandberg space travels Tambor
guitar Tandberg car wash and pizza hmm
Tambor is a common surname in norway
there are a lot of companies called
tampered I think down over 100 companies
called Hamburg there is a tiny
connection though to tombery get all the
fabric famous worldwide for premiere
audio equipments like a radios receivers
amplifiers and speakers tape recorders
but in 1978 Tambor Grado fabric went
bankrupt so a few business people they
acquired the name the spelling the fonts
like this a trademark they acquired it
and kept it in a drawer for about 10
years until the business genius young
Kristin oops all I really mean it
business genius and the video fool
projector from Tel Aviv care for stings
Institute joined forces
approximately in 1990 to form what is
now known as
Tandberg and that is the story that this
is where the story starts the first
proper product was the Tandberg vision
Wikipedia dictionaries encyclopedias
they say it was out in 91 but that's
really not true because it's it wasn't
until 1993 that they were finished
debugging the hardware and the software
so it could actually be used for
anything it used to burn up actually
because it's got so warm
but eventually it worked and it was kind
of a successful product as the
cornerstone to a large series of
products division series that you see
here the vision series was replaced by
the classic and mxp lines of products
and then in around 2008 there was a new
series of products coming out actually
the first line of products where we used
C++ so that's worth mentioning and this
was in 2010 from 2008 r2 and the state
of art and by 2010 I don't have all the
numbers but I have a few of the revenue
of the tambour growing session over the
years there should be more or less exact
but there is another number that I find
even more interesting and and that is
how much is invested into R&D how many
engineers do you have because that also
tells you something about how much do
the organization believe in itself if
you don't really believe in yourself you
will not invest much in our Indian
engineers but if you do then you just
you just invest a lot into R&D and to
create new products and make more money
and grow and this is an interesting
curve and at a time we had offices
around the world it was still focused in
in Oslo Atlas occur most people but we
had offices in UK in India of course in
the US and also in New Zealand we
participated Tandberg was a great place
to work for three years we were on the
top of that list actually
second place in 2008 we lost to flea
talk the rumor says that I just got new
uniforms the day before the surveys
so that's might explain the 2008 defeat
but it was a great place to work April
19 2010 that was the acquisition was
completed all right
and this is where the my story ends in
this talk I continue the inter Cisco for
nine years but this talk is about
Tandberg not Cisco so let's take a look
at the product kind of a typical example
or what we did at least Sarkar
the Tandberg called xc90 actually I
don't think it's end of life
well it's probably end of life but it's
still out there
so it's worth studying sure it's a
really really mean machine
it's a codec that could encode and
decode all the on video signals
basically one of the features was that
you could connect a lot of devices to it
and the way it operated is that you
could come connect four HD input streams
into the device at the same time and we
are talking 1080p and then compress this
and code it and send it out as for
example h.264 and some audio codecs on
to some internet over the Internet to
somewhere else where they pick up this
and decode it have you ever tried to rip
a DVD or a blu-ray it takes no no of
course you haven't
it takes a while
this one could take four 1080p HD media
streams and rip it on the fly without
delay and send it out we are talking
about a few milliseconds delay so it's
powerful machine and while doing that it
could also receive four HD streams
and presented locally to displays and
speakers it was a really and is a really
powerful machine if you were going it's
very common to hear but you can be just
by stuff coming off the shelf equipment
enthalpy and then you're off we go now
that's not true if you were going to do
something similar at the time you would
need several racks of equipment to get
the same type of performance so that was
the challenge to put all this electronic
in and program it and and just looking
at the specs what's inside in the audio
board here we had one big FPGA nine
audio DSPs we had the PowerPC to
orchestrate it all it was sixteen layers
of electronics next to it just above it
it was a video board even stronger there
were ten da Vinci chips which each have
four courses 40 cores five F PJs and
this ball was had twenty two layers of
electronics apparently at the time it
was the most advanced PCB ever
constructed here in Norway you don't
typically create electronics we're 22
layers of copper but with it and in
addition there was this traditional
audio board so from a geek point of view
what we're talking about here is a piece
of electronic that with this designed
ourself 10,000 components four to four
layers of on the PCBs 56 processes
course of different types we even have
different endianness on some of them
communicating fast with each other and
it was all run by several million lines
of code written in C and C++
we've from we came up with this idea we
are going to make this one it took 20
months to complete
this codec and ship it out into the
market and I remember 20 months at the
time it was really long time because we
were used to cycle times like 12 14 15
months and somewhere though we will
never be finished 20 months that's the
disaster but once we were out there and
started making money on this one it was
like alright ok it's working but the
very interesting thing to note here is
how many software engineers that are
involved in a project like this 40 50
software engineers compared to four or
five people working on electronics to
three on the mechanics and design and so
on
some organizations creating boxes like
this they optimized the development
process around hardware engineers the
electronic engineers the Tandberg really
deeply deeply understood that we are a
software company and we our development
process is focused around software
development and the other disciplines
they have to kind of follow that pace
instead so looking at kind of developed
and printed practices that we were used
in the Saturn project we used continuous
paneling always attack high risk first
very heavy focus on feedback mechanisms
continuing integration and this was in
2007 and right and we used the dashboard
for visualizing the status throughout
the projects we divided the teams in the
way you see here and for everyone
educated in modern ways of doing stuff
you will realize that that's the wrong
way to do it but it worked for us we
everything was developed in parallel
hardware software everything was
happening at the same time when we
started there was no handovers between
electronics to the software and so on we
used eye trations and timeboxing
their daily 15 minutes morning assembly
of the elders that's what I call it
who is the elders in this organization
well you decide do you want to be on the
meeting or not it's open meeting and
those meeting of the elders are still
running at least occur to Dianna sets
it's a successful way of meeting and
synchronizing effort and we had early
and many prototypes during those 20
years so when we have this product we
had very powerful codec that we could
now reuse the same IDs and make simpler
versions of it not so powerful but
cheaper but we could also make
specialized versions so desktop version
and also have the rooms just like this
one released in March 2010 the DX NIDA
x90 and this is a nice comment to get
back from the analysts this is what I
wanted and the e x9 T it was a really
beautiful piece of video conferencing
equipment but the same technology also
went into this system that we also sold
typically for big there were there were
some corporations that came in and said
we want 12 of these and have them
installed around all our offices er in
the world and together with things we
already have like PC based solutions
fantastic networking products this is
the secret by the way and video
conferencing if you want to compete in
video conferencing forget about the end
points focus on the networking side
that's where the difficult stuff is not
10 points fantastic stuff and a lot of
other things we had already and in 2010
2009 what also 2008 we were winning so
hard that I think the competitors
basically gave up maybe that was the
reason why Cisco gave up and just
acquired us instead of competing with us
so some observations from tambour the
development process oh that must have
been rigid month wasn't the only way to
do things like this is to have a rigid
process isn't it well we had a number as
an engineer joining Tandberg back in the
days from Anna this was the first
impression impression no documentation
no routines people were just fooling
around
not following plans decisions postponed
nobody decided little respectful
management little modernization lack of
precision sloppiness and people were not
really working hard but then after a
while you started to notice that hmm
people communicate it's a very high
focus on important stuff there's an
embedded slack in the organization
people have time to do the right things
they can relax they can think they can
collaborate and and so on and innovate
continuous planning effective decisions
autonomous organization very high
respect for the doers no integration
period spectacular products deliver
early the product just came up very
early and we were running at a
sustainable pace yes
it's I will come back to that one
actually and if not I have something
about it remind me if I don't spend time
on that so while you still saw the
negative stuff you started to appreciate
the positive side even more and you
forgot about the negatives and if you
just look at the positive components the
observations from Tandberg if you just
look at this list doesn't sound too bad
this is agile as its scrum lean damming
it's none of these it's very it was very
compatible with agile scrum lean damming
when I came in I already knew and had
studied very well
agile scrum lean Deming I knew it and I
was looking at what we did and
tambourine it's like it's similar but
it's different and once you know the
founders and those who are involved in
Tandberg in the beginning they didn't
read books like that they use common
sense and their gut feeling first
iterations and they continuously improve
them this is something that Tandberg
basically invented it was invented in
house but it's certainly a good thing
and the nice thing is that everything
you see here you can find kind of the
reasons to academic background for it if
you like in books like this I recommend
all of those books and that's why they
are here if you want to understand if
you want to understand and the region
industrial success then you will find it
in those books together with the slides
that are just presented I think and
there are some thoughts about positive
negative and positive components because
everything has a negative component as
well as a positive component so if you
want to improve something it's so easy
to focus on a negative side and try to
fix that without necessarily realizing
that you are reducing the positive side
by even more and a typical signature for
a mediocre organization and then I'm
talking about anything that doesn't look
like Hamburg
they are often like this boring boring
boring
there isn't much negative here and but
there isn't much positive either yeah I
just they just exist but if you look at
great organizations often you find
profiles and signatures like this
Collins says it like this in good to
great managing your problems can only
make you good actually he is good in
certain media crap
whereas building your opportunities is
the only way to become great Knut honor
against that's the same thing you go
Fulton and that you should continue
working on things you are already good
at and then you should rely on the
compliment I defer to create a team out
of this all right
so instead of following procedures and
rules and regulations and so on
we did have some very strong principles
of effective product development I'm
going to move the receiver on this one
on the other side because the clicker is
not properly working so we'll see how
this goes maybe anyway principles for
effective product development we all
know that few high-tech projects are
like running down a paved road where you
can see the goal in the end of the road
typical projects are more like extreme
orienteering and difficult terrain with
a group of people it's dark and at best
we have a sketchy map as guidance and
the key thing is also for a lot of
well-run project is that it doesn't
matter if not everyone reached the cabin
in the end of the day
I mean there is absolutely no success
unless all of them reach the cabin so
thinking about projects like this might
make you reconsider a few things that
are traditionally but the way we thought
about it was that we need to embrace the
chaos we need to embrace the uncertainty
we don't know what it's going to happen
and for this bus to pass through this
crossing and for everyone else to
survive it's about continuously
observing adapting changing and then
repeat over and over again
you can't plan you can't plan this at it
doesn't work because the context is
changing all the time there is another
way to do it so embrace chaos or learn
to surf the wave or whatever but just
deal with the complexity don't dream
about a simple world where everything is
called make your plans and then just run
the bus as fast as you can through this
crossing you have to celebrate
organization don't celebrate individuals
don't celebrate the teams or the
projects or whatever it's the whole
organization that should celebrate their
existence the success so and we did that
a lot in and typically the parties there
were before we launched products not
after it was actually and the intention
no no no we don't celebrate after the
project that's not many bits we need
celebrations when things are tough when
people are tired then we need a big
party so that was typical Tandberg 'we
also admire the doers try to create an
autonomous organization lift up and
praise the people that engineers that do
the sold ring writing code salespeople
that go out to customers with products
and get money to bring back into the
organized
that's what you need to do and you have
to do that systematically all the time
and lift them up and and admire them and
in Tandberg we had this thing called
productive and non productive and we
didn't want to have much more than 10%
non-productive x' and all the
non-productive they knew that they had a
very important role to make that day for
the engineer or the salesperson easier
and it was kind of a bit embarrassing to
be an unproductive but if you did a
really good job on supporting these two
roles then he felt good anyway but
that's we didn't call them corporate fat
overhead and things I'm but it was term
productive and non productive and we
didn't want that to go beyond 10%
sometimes it was 11 sometimes it was 12
but we try to keep that maximum 10
percent those who are working in a
company receiving salaries but not
really doing a real work we need we
focused on communication and they
realize that documentation is not a
really good way of communicating first
of all it's time-consuming it's boring
and the customer are not paying for it
usually it's just something that you do
because you think you have to do it and
one of the first thing I heard when I
joined Tandberg was that model
documentation only if the customer pays
for it so when we started to deliver
stuff to to defense industry for example
we also big customers in defense
industry also we delivered equipment to
oil rigs and oil industry etc high and
medical devices we could do that but
then they had to pay for us writing the
documentation that they needed
for other customers they didn't care
that I just want the equipment and a
simple user manual and off they go
but also another thing about a lack of
documentation is that you probably know
I've seen this in some organizations the
senior engineers they are hiding behind
piles of documentation that have
everything it's like a wall so a junior
program incoming junior engineer coming
in it's not allowed to communicate over
that wall it's like oh you have to read
that stuff before you can talk to me and
it's it's usually just garbage anyway in
those documents and if your work walked
around an office engineering office at
least okay you wouldn't see ring binders
we never used tools for documenting our
design internal behavior or something
like that but we did communicate all the
time so the picture on the left are kind
of typical introduced slack
it seems like everyone understands that
you can't fail a washing machine
completely and and cram in a lost sock
into it and then slam the door and then
put it on if you do that you know that
you will get crap out so the concept of
slack is something that most people
understand to some extent and and we
understand that if we have really
terrific transfers for example maybe we
just put that one thing into into the
washing machine to optimize for
effectiveness instead of optimizing for
efficiency we don't have the difference
on those two words in Norwegian but in
English it's perfectly clear efficiency
in this case would be to have as much
clothes as possible into the washing
machine to get maximize the throughput
but effectiveness would be to have the
right amount of clothes into it so that
you get good results every time
for an organization doing difficult
stuff it's kind of similar look at the
one in the middle there what is it go
for what is this call 15 puzzle here
it's not a really hard person but it
would be really hard if you didn't have
any slack and and this is this is an
illustration of if you have hard
problems you need a lot of slack into
the organization that's the only way you
can solve it and you also need the slack
to be able to create the tools you need
you have to you need the slack to
sharpen your sword to improve your tools
you need slack to innovate units like to
think you need the more the harder the
problem is the more slack you need and
this is something that was very clearly
sad and communicated in the tambour
culture and and snowed HSP was one of
them leading in engineering it was
really good at this if that when we had
kind of problems struggling to get
products out he helped introduce more
slack into the system so that we could
solve it and then move on the typical
reaction in most organizations is to do
the opposite and that is to apply
pressure and put more stuff into it and
draw people harder and that's like
pitting in the last piece here it stops
if you're interested in this Tom DeMarco
has written a book about slack very
explains very clearly why doesn't work
to add pressure to knowledge work right
thank you
product development in this case Bavaro
the observer effect remember that film
are we seen it anyway they had this idea
that it was possible to to observe to
figure out how a kitchen was used and
that the person being observed didn't
change the behavior by this one
observing of course that didn't happen
but the observer effect is like if you
if you take an example if you stand if
you put yourself behind someone typing
writing code it's a fair chance that
that person will actually rather write
add codes into the code base rather than
deleting code from the code base things
like that you are affecting the
performance by watching it's also more
it's less likely that that person will
suddenly sit back and think for a half
an hour so but just by observing your
disturbing knowledge work you're
disturbing knowledge workers you're
disturbing teams and projects that are
trying to do something difficult now if
the individual if the team if the
project needs this information to go
forward so that they come up with these
kind of feedback mechanisms themself
then it's fine but if you have some kind
of corporate measure metric kind of
system get rid of it you don't want it
because you are destroying knowledge
work the worst management by objectives
instant is the worst strategy ever
business strategy ever invented
this ID that you could set a target a
goal and a lot a lot of people run
towards that goal and it's it doesn't
work they might reach that objective but
then they are so tired that are not
willing to go to the next objective or
they quit the company or they leave you
for all the reasons but there is another
way of doing this which can have a
similar effect you can point out the
direction and say this is approximately
where we are going and a nice way of
pointing out the direction is instead of
pointing you just put boundaries and say
we are not going to do anything outside
of this boundary but inside this
boundary Eretz and then you get kind of
a sector which is somehow pointing out
in the direction and as an example of
that is that everyone that started in
town Berg after a couple of weeks they
have this idea oh yeah if you do this
and that then grandma can talk to her
grandchildren before they go to
kindergarten and things like that I mean
it's a nice ID but it was very very
clearly stated no way they come
to body didi we were not going to make
those kind of systems because we had
boundaries that basically said we are
only going to make products and sell
products to large successful businesses
with loads of money that is that are
willing to pay us loads of money for our
products so whenever someone came up
with this kind of marginalized ID that
honor and then people can sit and watch
football matches together and so on no
way
and that's one that's that's a way to
point out the direction for a group of
people trying to develop high-tech
products but at the same time you should
break the rules and and it was even part
of the initial training for all
employees was that no no we don't accept
that you just follow rules because you
want to follow rules that's no excuse
for doing stupid stuff if you think it
is a bad idea
break the rule and do your thing instead
of an example that could be well we had
people that helped
buying disks and RAM and computer
equipment for example and that's
typically place you should go to get
stuff sources sourced if you needed a
new disk that's where you might go but
we were also told in kind of the initial
training that but you are not allowed to
move your problem on to someone else and
then sit back and wait for it to be
solved within a couple of days because
you know you can go to the to any store
and buy this stuff put it into your
computer and you can continue working so
there was no excuse you couldn't kind of
blame your problems on some kind of IT
department or a support organization
that was supposed to do it so break the
rules was built into how we were working
and it was also encouraged by management
you should reward courage and failures
and the worst thing I hear is this I do
it right the first time it's it's nice
in some contexts but when it comes to
hard problems that you're trying to
solve you can't do it right the first
time you have to iterate you have to
learn you have to do it over and over
again until you succeed so you should
celebrate and reward courage and you
should also celebrate failures and think
about them as learning this boy would
never be able to become a rocket
scientist if he was supposed to do it
right the first time I mean that's that
would stop the progress of this thing
focus on the whole product if you look
at monster truck on the right-hand side
and you consider each component
everything is better on the thing on the
right-hand side compared to the left
the wheels are large and engine is
stronger the lights are probably better
than the chair is fabulous and
everything is better on the right-hand
side but it's not a balanced solution
what you see on the left-hand side it's
balanced solution it's a result of
systems thinking the thing on the rent
right hand side is the result of
Taylorism and reductionism where the IDS
oh let's take this problem divide it
into small pieces have different teams
that work on these components and then
assemble that together in the end
it's kind of obvious when you look at
the car but for all of us that have been
involved in software we recognize
software solutions that look a lot like
on the right hand side and you can you
can get balanced solutions if you force
everyone to think about the whole
product all the time and if you avoid
component teams and focus on components
inside the product do continuous
planning what I didn't mention when I
talked about the Saturn project was that
we also had this room with lots of glass
on the walls and there were post-it
notes all over the room it was in the
space area for those who remember and it
was January February March the months on
this these windows on the post-it notes
it was things that we thought would be
finished everyone involved in the
project can walk over to that wall and
move those post-it notes to the where
they thought it should have been so we
didn't have this kind of Gantt diagrams
and actually Gantt diagrams was
forbidden in the organization it's like
cancer in an organization in incredible
pain spore and probably impossible to
get rid of once you are infected but so
we didn't have these kind of plans that
people were supposed to follow and so on
we were doing continuous planning by
moving those post-it notes and everyone
could do so not just the project mother
this is this is an idea that we tend to
appreciate when we hear it from kind of
big names like Winston Churchill and
iced over
plans are nothing planning is everything
we kind of hear that sounds cool and
then we go back and they make a silly
plan
static plan but nobody says it better
than Mike Tyson himself and so there are
a few plants that actually survived
their reality
so instead focus on continuous planning
that's what you want to do
aim for approximately right rather than
accurately wrong that could be used in
many context but also in this context
when we made new products and we did a
few every year with big products like
the c90 was a typical really big project
but we had similar sized project running
continuously churning out of the
organization the typical approach was
like hmm yeah we knew the product oh
let's let's run and then we started
developing the product and we were
learning while we were doing it but also
but sometimes we just went off in some
direction and we had to kind of work
with Salesforce worked with the market
so that they moved the target and and we
could hit it not necessarily in the
build side but somewhere close and for a
for a video conferencing market at the
time must be still the case but probably
not that wasn't really a problem because
anything was good enough and it was a
none mature market we were growing it
very fast so nice products approximately
around here would be a winner instead of
thinking thinking thinking
mmm calculate calculate wait for 12
months and them maybe and a new so
so this was a much better approach to
aim for approximately right that I'm not
correctly wrong I just let this video
run for a few seconds this idea about
sometimes when you work with software
releases we are also talking
release trains if those release trains
are running very seldom then everyone
wants their feature on to that release
right now it's so important everything
becomes equally important everything
needs to go on that train because it
doesn't go very often and and a lot of
the features and things that you want on
this release train doesn't really need
to be there but it's there just in case
so if you start running these release
trains much much more frequent than only
the high priority features and change
requests will need to go onto that train
and maybe if you wait a couple of rides
into town then this feature might an
hour it wasn't that important anyway we
choose another one so the key thing is
that if you release seldom then
everything becomes equally important and
it's too much if you release very often
you got not only get a linear growth now
improvement you get an exponential
improvement because there is a lot of
things that is suddenly it doesn't need
to go into town anyway seek early
feedback Pixar says that our films don't
have a finished are just released so
that's part of the timeboxing but also I
use the green bananas to illustrate that
we shipped products out to the market
that was not finished yet
and we did it deliberately it was on
purpose because we needed the feedback
and we couldn't wait because timing is
everything
there is another company that do this
and it did it while we were working as
well I think they were called Apple or
something like that that made that foam
that couldn't even do mms when it was
launched into the market I mean that was
completely common among all telephones
at the time but iPhone didn't have
support for MMS plus a lot of other
things that you would expect on
but I had some success with it and so
did we
so it's about kind of making the
customers understand that well it's it
will be better but this is what we have
now and then if they are interested then
you can continue investing in that if
they're not interested and he has said
yourself a lot of time by not completing
the product component in the direction
you initially thought and this is kind
of similar ID but never reveal your next
products don't have roadmaps and we
named it we called it the Sinclair
effect I don't know if that is the
correct thing but that was referring to
Alistair Sinclair
you know spectrum and hamster and so on
the problem he was the kind of the
British genius comparable to Bill Gates
but he had a problem that every time he
presented the product
he just had to talk about the things he
had in the lab that was coming out a few
months later the result being that
people didn't buy this they were waiting
for the next thing always and then he
went bankrupt so and we didn't want that
to happen so when we launched our
products we told the market and we told
the sales people our own sales people
they got to know this at the same day as
the markets so our sales people didn't
know what we were working on nobody knew
what we were working until it was
released once again there is another
company I think it's called something
like that they have the same strategy
they don't tell about what's the next
product is about the next iPhone the
next Mac Pro was it it happened it's
launched and then the Salesforce knows
about it and customers knows about it
and then the product is out it also
meant we were never late because nobody
knew so if we have the product we hope
to kind of ship in February and we're in
general we could always say let's ship
in the neighborhood sir
so that's known no roadmaps that was the
Tandberg way avoid corporate standards
and procedures and this is an
illustration we all know that what fall
is bad but it's every time of every type
of canned procedures this is the way to
do it routines that you should follow or
whatever has this similar effect then it
works as long as the troupe it is low
maybe but as soon as you increase the
TripIt you put it on the pressure the
end result is random so this is an
attempt to illustrate upper management
trying to figure out what the
engineering is doing I've seen this over
and over again in other places not in
Hamburg and forget about innovation
workshops it was actually forbidden to
have these spaghetti post-it notes
innovation workshops in in Tandberg
because our problem wasn't innovation or
in the capacity to innovate was much
higher than our capacity to execute and
deliver stuff so we rather focused on
executing and deliver stuff but we also
knew that if there was enough slack in
the organization we would get
innovations micro innovations on the
products that we had and if we were at
times where we needed lots of
information weak innovations we could
just reduce the pressure on the
organization introduce more slack into
the system and we would become
innovative and they had while we didn't
have these kind of workshops we did have
kind of playtime's we encouraged
skunkworks
collaborations between people in between
projects and whatever supposed to do and
so on collective ownership I think it's
a very important idea I'm not going to
elaborate on that one but also in code
that means you should never have code
snippets that is owned by some
individuals or a team or whatever
everyone should be able to change every
piece of code in your codebase
as long as they work for you of course
in your organization no time writing or
detailed cross control we didn't have
that we didn't have any system even for
recording holidays inserting the
contract thirty seven and a half hours
per week five or maybe it was six weeks
of holiday you deal with it
we didn't have a system for recording
that at all there is some company called
SAS Institute that always come up high
on the great place to work and young man
said something very discreet to dance
you know it's not that difficult to get
a great company it's it's about you know
treating your employees like they are
you know not criminals and if you look
at mechanisms that organizations put to
place a lot of these mechanisms are
there because organization doesn't trust
the employees and it's it's it's a
terrible and slow welding I used to say
you should and we used to say you should
always optimize for you ninety-eight
percent trust worth employees that's and
if you have a few non trustworthy forget
about and don't let the other suffers
because there might be a chance that
someone is misusing the system build the
company on trust that's that's the
recommendation there and last but not
least start working in an environment
like this it's very exhausting if you're
under a wrong type there were actually
some companies that we couldn't hire
from because we needed we will never be
able to reprogram them and but what we
were looking for passion attitude and
skills and that is you you can get into
the engineering organization if you
didn't have the passion and attitude and
the skills and we did that in the hiring
process where typical candidates met
usually ten different people inside of
ten Berghe and we didn't have an agenda
what we were asking but but we were
looking for passion
and attitudes and often sometimes skills
and in the end of the interview rounds
we just met and if everyone was like
then we hired if someone was like hmm I
don't know there's something then we
didn't hire we didn't need to hire if
there was someone that we weren't sure
about so that summarizes it I know it
should be 14 principles because Toyota
Way has 14 principle Deming who is 14
principle so how to rely on this break
the rules because that do you actually
have 21 and I'm not going to read them
out loud again and this is what I call
the Tandberg way of Engineering thank
you that's it
[Applause]
I'm open for questions oh I I wasn't
really prepared for that question so I
don't really know what to say but now
the fact is that the leaf soccer team
Tandberg was very heavily based on the
soccer so when I gave this talk for nine
years similar kind of talks for nine as
I called it a little soccer way and not
a tunberg way the leaf soccer team is
stronger than ever and the current
product portfolio is beyond spectacular
so this is examples actually the
similarities down there and Cisco
contributed a lot we grew up we became
more mature but when I talk about more
mature we didn't change much of the
Tandberg way but more mature in the way
that we understood that our products
were used in some kind of context so
this was very much improved to to see
the bigger picture we also learnt a lot
about um kind of logistics shipping
unboxing money-making production and so
on so we even designed started to design
the frames and look at this there are
even wheels here so that you can take
this one and you can tilt it up put it
into the elevator go up and tilt it down
and then bring it into the office things
like that we we didn't knew that while
we were tombery maybe we've got air but
that process was accelerated very much
as we joined Cisco and a lot of machine
learning artificial intelligence stuff
and I have to mention Schneider because
while I say that o'clock's though was
arguably the most important for the
Tandberg success it's no there should be
mentioned as the most important for
making sure that cisco got value out of
this
acquisition because he was leading
Tandberg into Cisco not only making room
for Tandberg inside of Cisco but also
making sure that we changed Tandberg in
such a way that it was compatible with
the Cisco way of doing things so when
you say what what happened did we have
to change much and I would say yes we
did have to change much
somehow it was good some of it was bad
the reason why I called the Tandberg way
here is that maybe one third of the
principles that I listed was not it's
not really true anymore inside of Cisco
but they were replace their are replaced
with other things that are better but
different so and another thing that
happened was that since Cisco paid 19
billion Norwegian Kroners rothenburg a
lot of money came into Norway into oslo
into actually around a soccer area so
all of these companies have something to
do with tunberg most people stayed most
people in the engineering in the
Tandberg engineering stayed after the
acquisition because cisco is a really
nice company to work for ever ever get a
chance go for it
it's of the big companies it's one of
the coolest companies to work for but
also there were some people out there or
I'm not doing this so they maybe they
went out and started some of these
companies that are listed here so a lot
of positive things happened
not for Tandberg Tandberg died but a lot
of things happen for the video
conferencing industry and for the
business and especially around early
sarkar area most well yes that was one
question another one yes
absolutely not and this is actually
something that I'm asked over and over
again when I do presentations like this
usually in when I was working for Cisco
I'm not working for Cisco by the way I
left one month ago so I can say whatever
I want
that's useful to clarify I'm working for
Ecuador now completely different
industry but when I did these kind of
presentations also inside of Cisco I got
this question about how yeah we want to
do that give us a recipe you missed my
talk you can't have a recipe for doing
things you can't have procedures
routines this is something you have to
grow and what I usually say is that team
and organization that is willing to do
continuous improvement every day will
always outperform someone that has kind
of given up to improve one day it will
they will pass and I'm not sure if this
is correct but there is this saying from
Toyota saying that we don't try to make
the perfect car we just try to suck less
every day so that's why we have the
Toyota way of doing things and I would
say this is also a result of the
Tandberg way it's trying to suck less
every day and you can I think you can
take a lot of organizations and grow
them in some kind of sensible direction
but then you have to get rid of a few
mechanisms that are there which are
impossible to pass for example if you
have if you believe in in measuring your
employees if you believe in detailed
project cost control things like that
you have to get rid of a lot of things
in order to grow in a sensible direction
yes no yep
ah gut feeling to some exam
number but it was also while there was a
complete disconnect between engineering
and sales there were a few over honours
and also engineers were supposed to go
out and visit customers and spend time
with customers so we basically knew we
had the common shared understanding or
where the market is going so the
decision process is difficult to kind of
pinpoint but it was there and it was
very very precise and correct yes and
that is a very important point we used
what we made now if you are building
nuclear power stations or missiles you
might not be an expert user on your own
equipment but we were in the lucky
position where everyone working with
this could actually use our own products
so we were expert users and engineers at
the same time and if that is the case
you might need to organize your
engineering differently than if you were
doing power stations or nuclear missiles
yes
yeah we it depends on what you mean with
fares competition we had competitors
really nice cool competitors polycomb
was one of them from an engineering
point we we really enjoyed competing
with them they came up with great stuff
we try to copy some of their stuff we
try to come up with great stuff and so
on we was a relay but after while we
were winning too hard so we didn't have
much competition we were driving the
market basically we had 50% market share
if I think if we were if we were
competing a very mature market with a
lot of good players and it wasn't
difficult to find a new product that
were appreciated and successful I think
we would have needed to change something
but we wouldn't need to change much of
the principles and that's the that's the
beauty of principles procedures they
break down immediately when context is
changing principles they have a tendency
to kind of survive change for a while I
think you could have used nearly all of
this also in competing highly
competitive market yes yes I agree
now it's a very valid observation and we
have actually been studied many times by
also my teas and slow and and MBAs and
and so on and yes there is fascination
when they are studying us and we really
and we did understand that they come
from another point of view but yes we
had discussions and this is kind of
different from a typical MBA study yes
but we made 19 billion Norwegian
chromosome D so yes yeah yeah yeah and
that's that's nice and it's I'm not
going to bring that into but you know
the difference between science and but
I'm doing it anyway science and religion
is that religion is invented while
science is something that given enough
time someone that doesn't know anything
about this will discover the same type
of principles like gravity for example
any group of people would civilization
eventually will this discover gravity
and the physical principles I think
something like this runs here as well
it's common sense in the bottom that and
and fast repeating and continuous
improvement etc that ends up with
something like this and nonsense
wouldn't work in an open source
environment because we would never hear
about them they would kind of disappear
so by the nature of open source I would
agree it looks like kind of compare and
compatible with this yes yep
that was from the very very very
beginning and I should I should actually
show if I understood your question
correctly but the thing is that this guy
young Chris turn up so I found when I
did talk about this 10 years ago I found
an interview that I did in 2002 and he
said that I didn't I didn't work in a
regular corporate environment I had to
kind of get out of this and create
something new basically another thing
was that momentum is the most important
thing we just you just have to find you
just have to rev up your engine and
start driving very very fast in some
direction it will outperform those who
are trying to steer the car nicely into
and go and the last thing which even
have a really nice calculation error
it's about it's it's okay to be
approximately right it doesn't have to
be perfect in other way and if you
classify these things I think it would I
put it into autonomy momentum and
approximately right and this was the
starting point for Tandberg in 1990 as
well
eventually he he said I don't understand
what you're doing in engineering in a
way you are talking to each other and
thinking and discussing instead of doing
stuff
so apparently he he asked to have his
axis removed from engineering but then
Perry Cox tie around the engineering
instead yeah but yeah a business genius
but also how to create an organization
from the very beginning so we never had
to change much we could just build on
top of these principles for two decades
it's the last session so I think it's
possible to have one more question or so
but though there was it's probably good
at it
and grab a beer alright so k there we
lost questions actually I had expected
that question as well but and it's a
really really really good question but I
haven't prepared anything the question
is like Apple cannot tell their
customers because it's a
business-to-consumer thing but we are a
business-to-business and how do we
manage expectations and if there was the
question was there anything negative
about Hamburg I would also have to
mention that some customers some big
players in the market they called us the
tambourine he said you are technology
geniuses but marketing morons and one of
the reasons was that we didn't have any
roadmaps we didn't we were not able to
give expectations for how they're going
to evolve their technology internally
even though I reliant on our technology
so we tried to say oh but we promise
that it will be good but it wasn't good
enough for them so the lack of roadmap
was a good point but it was also a weak
points so you're perfectly right in
asking now for all right thank you very
much
[Applause]